there was anger and sadness as
supporters gathered at the headquarters
of the future forward party to watch the
verdict the Constitutional Court judges
ruled that the opposition party be
dissolved and at 16 leaders banned from
politics for 10 years the case
surrounded the more than six million
dollars given to the party by its leader
Tana toe and wrong room ruin kit the
party said it was alone which was being
paid back and therefore exempt from laws
in Thailand that restrict the amount of
money that can be given to a political
party by an individual the judges
disagreed and ruled that it was a
donation well in excess of the legal
limits future-forward says it will now
become a political movement and fight on
they wanted to destroy us this is the
time to prove them wrong we have to
become stronger they want to stomp us
into the ground therefore this is the
time to stand firm it's not the time to
be sad or cry we don't have time for
that this but he delved into areas that
others haven't liked vowing to reform
one of the most powerful political
forces in Thailand the military but
their ideas proved popular with many
Thais perhaps too popular and the
military and the courts moved against
them the election last year the first
since of 2014 coup was also future
forwards first and had won more than 6
million votes it was an outcome that
perhaps surprised the military that had
spent the preceding years devising a new
political system that many believe was
designed to maintain its grip on power
it now seems inevitable that Thailand's
fight for democracy will once again be
taken to the streets we can't live like
this
Thailand is going backward we have no
choice but to stand together please come
out people we cannot only rely on tenets
horn anymore this was the fourth major
opposition party to be dissolved by the
court in 13 years most of future
forwards MPs will be able to continue in
Parliament under a different party name
but the ban on the leaders will increase
the majority of the government which
perhaps coincidentally faces a vote of
no-confidence next week Wayne hey
algae's
era Bangkok